[Music]
listen i have a story for you
something the examiner will love a
healing
possibly divine a girl performing
miracles after a visitation from the
virgin mary in chicago
new york do you see every demographic on
this planet
is eating this up give me the exclusive
all right i think i got this all set up
what do you say we do a couple
real easy questions how many are gonna
watch mary wants to reach as many people
as possible
maybe millions
[Music]
there are people out there that don't
believe in your miracles
how would you respond to those folks
seeing is believing and why do you think
mary chose you
i opened myself up and welcomed her in
witnesses of the virgin mary draw
millions of faithful
each year the vatican's been tasked to
investigate
this visitation from the blessed virgin
i have read several libraries worth on
the supernatural
investigated half of those miracles
prove him all false
[Applause]
[Music]
she's here you think there could be
other forces at play here
when god builds a church the devil
builds a chapel
next door don't doubt her
doubt weakens faith
[Applause]
[Music]
hail mary full of grace pray for us
sinners
now and at the hour of our death
this is not the work of the virgin mary
it's the work of the unholy
faith and and poverty
believe in her
offer your soul
to mary
holy mary mother of god the lord is with
you
[Music]
you